now to the escalating migration crisis
on the european union's border with
belarus record number of asylum seekers
have been attempting to cross into eu
member state poland in recent days
poland has constructed a border fence
and deployed thousands of soldiers to
turn them back a move that contravenes
international law poland and the eu
accused belarus of manufacturing the
crisis by sending asylum seekers to the
eu's borders a number have already died
of hypothermia or exhaustion and as
temperatures get colder there's no
resolution in sight
from raw in this story let's bring in dw
correspondent jack parock he's at the
border between poland and belarus jack
can you paint us a picture about the
conditions on the ground there
let me just give you a rundown of what
we've just experienced we were informed
that there was an intervention of
perhaps four iraqi migrants about a
kilometer or so down the road behind me
as we drove there uh to try and speak to
these people there was a police block
saying that this was the edge of the
exclusion zone that's a three kilometer
zone away from the border and they said
that we were not able to access those
people that we understood were there
this shows you the difficulty for
transparency and the difficulty for
reporting the situation on the ground we
do know from the polish border
authorities they say that yesterday they
intercepted 605 people which would
indicate that the numbers of people
trying to cross is going up
now jack you've spoken to activists on
the polish side who've witnessed
pushbacks who is behind this
indeed abby we actually just met a local
woman who said that she had been in
contact with a group of iraqi migrants a
family she gave us the phone numbers of
these people after she said she had
given them food and water and tried to
help them in any way she could we've
been in contact uh via messaging with
this family with one of the members of
this family who's on an iraqi dialing
code he sent me a video which was pretty
difficult to watch begging us for help
and saying that they were freezing they
need water holding up a sort of plastic
bottle with dirty water in it there are
three children in that video
we met the woman on the polish side of
the border just on the edge of the
exclusion zone and they dropped us a pin
with their geographic location which
indicated that they are now over the
border in belarus they've also messaged
me just in the last few minutes to say
that they won't try and enter poland
again because they're too tired
this evening we expect it to be like it
was last night bitterly bitterly cold
the situation is very difficult because
the activists don't really know where
where anyone is and they fear
repercussions for their actions in
trying to support people from the polish
government
now dire conditions the weather is not
helping it's going to get colder and now
there's these reports that people in the
border exclusion zone are getting
messages from the polish interior
ministry warning them that belarusian
authorities are trying to poison
migrants
indeed we just got a message again on
our phone
being in the border zone saying do not
cross the polish border and do not take
pills from belarusian soldiers it was
about the same time yesterday we
received that message as well we
understand that those messages started
being delivered the day before we don't
exactly know what that means what the
suggestion is of what the belarusian
soldiers are meant to be
giving to these migrants but clearly
this is a very scary situation for them
as we know there are many families and
as you said we really don't know how
this situation is going to be resolved
we already do know that a number of
people have died in this forest already
during this crisis
dw correspondent jack parak at the
border between poland and belarus thank
you jack
i'm joined now by poland's deputy
foreign minister martin chadduch
minister thank you for taking the time
to speak to dw
thank you very much for having me
as we just said there it appears that
your government is pushing migrants back
from belarus migrants trying to claim
asylum in the european union is that the
case
no it's not the case actually it's an
artificial crisis
orchestrated by the russian regime i
mean
the charter flights has been
set by the belarusian regime all around
the middle east countries
so that the migrants not only asylum
seekers are encouraged somehow to go to
belarus and they're they're being used
as an instrument to destabilize the
eastern european and their boulders
let me just say that those people who
really need an asylum they can apply
for that
at the embassy of poland in iraq or
other countries or any other embassy in
minsk or um or middle east countries
yes it may be an orchestrated crisis as
you say by belarus but it is a crisis
nonetheless and we have our
correspondent there he's in the border
region right now and he says he's spoken
to activists on the polish side who've
witnessed these pushbacks and he's in
touch with migrants on the belarussian
side who say they were in poland but
were taken back across the border that's
illegal
well um
depends what what do you mean by saying
illegal according to what i mean the
geneva convention states that their
people shouldn't be pushed back to the
country where they came from when where
they are in danger so we are not pushing
back those people to um syria or i don't
know afghanistan they came legally to
belarus so sometimes of course the
redirector redirecting having in mind
the information that they are not in
germany because they really want to go
to germany mostly that's what they ask
us to do we want to go to germany to get
the asylum there once they are informed
that it's not germany they sometimes
they they decide by themselves to go
back to belarus to try the other or the
other way uh or they are just somehow
blocked by the polish
board guards do not enter the polish
territory because it's illegal if you
want to get to the polish territory then
you have to go to the crossing point
with the special documents with the visa
minister are you saying then if these
migrants have actually made it on to
polish soil that they are not being
pushed back by your officials
well uh what do you mean by saying push
backs there are i mean there are
informed that they are on the territory
of poland not german not germany
if they want to apply for asylum in in
in germany then it's not the way to do
on the polish territory so some of them
they do really decide to go back to um
to belarus the others
are informed that this is illegal what
they've done so they need to go on their
back but
if i may now of course we can discuss
about this procedure but
i think we should have in mind that it
is an orchestrated a hybrid attack um
by the russian regime that he has
invited those migrants to destabilize us
and as a revenge to our policy towards i
mean our european policy towards belarus
because when okasenka announced publicly
the possible migration crisis on the on
the border on the that very day when we
as the european union 27 countries
decided to sanction him him and the and
and the russian regime so it is a kind
of
revenge uh where the people are
instrumentalized by by lukashenko
minister i do want to ask you a little
bit more about belarus um
there's that border exclusion zone that
your government has set up and people
who are in that area appear to be
receiving messages that belarusian
authorities are trying to poison
migrants the same warning is on your
interior ministries website i'm just
going to read it there it says do not
take any pills or medication given to
you in belarus you may be poisoned
what evidence does poland have the
balleris is doing this
well we do have testimonies of those
migrants found already on the polish
side some of them um
told us that they were offered by the uh
by some of the the kgb officers with uh
special pills uh that was at the quite
at the very beginning of this crisis
when mr wukashenka wanted to attract the
interests of media
around this crisis so we found some deaf
corpse
on the
at the border that it was very probable
that some of them
were poisoned that's why we appeal to
those people do not take any any pills
from from them
i'd like to move on now there are
concerns that your country uh might be
going through at potentially a poll exit
the so-called poll exit we saw over the
weekend over a hundred thousand people
gather in the capitol there to show
their support for being in the european
union
and this was in reaction to the protest
about the polish constitutional court
ruling that national law supersedes eu
law is your government going down a path
towards a poll exit
not at all
we are a member of the eu are we going
to stay in the in the eu
eu
and i mean eu is a natural environment
for me for poland so nothing like that
of course there was a demonstration um
orchestrated by donald tusk by the
opposition leader more or less to
support him as the opposition leader
with a kind of fake argument that there
is a possible policy there is nothing
like this 90 percent of polls are um
there are i mean they do support our
membership
in the eu and also the government
supports our membership but of course
the constitutional tribunal just like
the federal tribunal constitution
tribunal in castro germany or
the same with the in the french case um
they said that the most important
law or legislation in poland in in our
countries is the constitution of poland
or um in case of germany or france the
same and that
we accept the eu regulations those which
are based on the eu treaties but those
uh regulations uh which are um written
in the polish constitutions um we do
also i'm somehow obliged to um to
observe those regulations i mean there
are competences of the eu and there are
competences of the member
member states
and let's keep it as it is
marcin
polish deputy foreign minister minister
thank you for taking the time to speak
with dw we appreciate it thank you very
much
thank you
you